من الاسئله والاتهامات واجهت المدير
التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك شوزي شو لدى مثوله
امام الكونجرس مشرع الحزبين اعربوا عن
شكوكهم في استقلاليه التطبيق عن الحكومه
الصينيه
لا نثق بان تيك توك ستتبنى القيم
الامريكيه بالحريه وحقوق الانسان
والابتكار تيك توك تبنت مرارا مسار المزيد
من السيطره والمراقبه والتلاعب يجب منع
تطبيقكم واتوقعوا ان تقول اي شيء لتفادي
هذه النتيجه
عن الحكومه الصينيه ليقدم تطمينات بان
معلومات المستخدمين ستكون تحت حمايه
القانون الامريكي هذا العام
اتعهد بالالتزامات الاتيه تجاهكم وتجاه
جميع مستخدمينه اولا ستكون السلامه وبخاصه
للمراهقين اولويه قصوى بالنسبه لنا ثانيا
سنعزز جدار الحمايه للبيانات من الوصول
الاجنبي غير المرغوب فيه ثالثا سيبقى تيك
توك مكانا لحريه التعبير ولن يجري التلاعب
به من اي حكومه ورابعا سنتحلى بالشفافيه
وسنمنح مراقبين مستقلين تابعين لجهات
خارجيه حق الاطلاع لنبقى مسؤولين عن
التزاماتنا
النائب الديمقراطي جمال بومان دافع عن تيك
توك متسائلا عن جدوى منع تطبيق يستخدمه
150 مليون امريكي وتدعيه ذلك على صانع
المحتوى قد يغيب الاجماع بشان ما قد يتخذ
من خطوات تمس مستقبل تيك توك في الولايات
المتحده لكن مشرعي الحزبين يتفقون في غياب
ثقتهم بالتطبيق شهاده المدير التنفيذي
لتيك توك كما المح غالبهم لم توفر تطمينات
بل زادت من اسئلتهم بسبب كويك الجزيره
واشنطن